I'll take that as a yes
what
the ring hey everybody so the Justice
League social media embargo is up so I
can talk about the film but I'm not
allowed to review it yet so this won't
be like a full review video but there
won't be any spoilers from the movie but
I know everybody just wants to know
what's going on what does everybody
think of it who's seen it so far so if
you're just finding me for the first
time be sure to subscribe to get
everything there's a ticket giveaway
that I'll explain at the end of the
video too and I'll try to explain you
know what I think they're going to do
next in terms of movies and structure
things based on my reaction to Justice
League so there were a lot of things
going into the movie a lot of rumors
that turned out not to be true there
were actually a lot of good things based
on all the late changes that they made
like bringing Joss Whedon in it's a
little hard to tell what scenes of Joss
Whedon and what scenes of Zack Snyder
but there were certainly a lot of
moments that felt like Joss Whedon type
jokes like just little moments of comedy
that he sneaks in but the really good
news is it the best thing that works
about the film is the characters I think
that's probably the most important thing
because you can't build a franchise
around an idea and it just gets me
really excited for say like the Aquaman
movie in the flash movie because both of
those characters were amazing if you've
heard reports that they're like
prioritizing the Flash character now
that they've finished the Aquaman movie
because he worked so well in Justice
League you'll understand once you see
the movie and some of the Flash's
interactions with specific other
characters are some of the most comic
book II things that you've ever read
about like if you're a big fan of the
classic flash comics no joke they did
some of the funniest classic flash stuff
that you've ever read about some of the
stuff that the TV show has also done
versions of - so even though Azra
Miller's flash looks very different the
aesthetic is completely different he
feels like the same flash although his
barry is a little bit younger than grant
gustin's barry this version of barry is
still a college kid and his dad Henry
Allen is featured in the movie so they
give you a little bit of background that
gets you ready for the flash movie but
he's played by the same actor that
played dr. Manhattan so this is you know
big sort of meta joke going on in the
film where dr. Manhattan is the father
of the flash and I know they're crossing
The Watchmen over and
comics right now so if you're a big
comic book fan and you are current with
what's been going on this past year in
the comics there'll be a lot of meta
jokes that you'll recognize that they
didn't necessarily intend to happen in
the movie like they're doing Dark
Knight's metal right now is this very
Batman centric big crossover event
obviously the movie isn't doing any of
that stuff but there are a lot of
metaphorical jokes about the characters
that are similar to what's going on at
Dark Knight's metal but I think that's
just a thing with movies this year where
you have darkness versus light in a
metaphorical way and a literal way like
it's even happening in the Star Wars
movies I think one of the Star Wars
trailer said darkness rises and the
light rises to meet it no surprise gal
gadot --tz-- Wonder Woman totally works
in this she's sort of the glue that
holds the characters together like
normally he would expect Superman to do
that but because of the plot Superman
isn't around at the beginning of the
film so she's sort of like the den
mother that keeps everybody from flying
apart and it's funny to see her do that
the way she did that for her group
during the Wonder Woman movie even
though in that movie she was quite
literally fresh off the boat so the way
the gal talked about her character in
this movie is that she's all grown up so
she's kind of like a big sister to the
other characters because like she said
in Batman V Superman I've fought things
that aren't from this planet before I
was totally unsurprised by Jason Momoa
as Aquaman
he was great I'm so excited for the
Aquaman movie now most of the comedy of
the character you've seen in a lot of
the recent trailers like where Batman is
normally like the big tough guy who's
really quiet but in this film he's the
one that has to go out and collect
everyone so that means that Aquaman gets
to be the big tough guy so they use that
for some very very good comedy so he
provided a really interesting
opportunity for Batman to just chill out
a little bit like he isn't quite as
severe as he was during Batman V
Superman generally I think people will
come out of this saying that it's much
better than Batman V Superman definitely
better than Suicide Squad but in general
I think most people's enjoyment of the
film will just depend on how much they
enjoy the characters like if you're a
big flash fan if you're big Jason Momoa
fan if you liked Wonder Woman you will
definitely love Justice League albeit
there are a lot of things that don't
work in the film like and it's pretty
clearly there are some weird things
before the film came out
were released like the CEO of Warner
Brothers gave them this mandate that the
film had to be less than two hours so
there was a lot of talk like why is it
less than two hours
they probably shot a four hour movie so
there are a couple problems with pacing
in them like burning through story just
because they were ordered to keep the
movie so short but most of those
problems are common to all super help
films even Marvel films still have
pacing issues but you have to remember
that they're bringing together the
members of the Justice League so like in
the first Avengers film you have to have
those beats with each of the characters
as they come to the team then you get to
the next film and you don't have to deal
with any of that you can get right into
the fun of things and speaking up sort
of like pacing the movie I felt like
they ended it in a way that will allow
them to do whatever they want to with
the next Justice League movie and they
won't be shackled to any particular plot
although obviously they set up a bunch
of very specific things like Steppenwolf
is coming to change the earth for
Darkseid so there's certainly a lot of
questions that they can answer with
future films but it's not like they're
painting themselves into a corner like
oh you did this post-credit scene where
a bunch of stuff happens so you have to
answer that but I think one of the big
changes they made was to the ending so
they don't paint themselves into a
corner they just have a little bit more
freedom with what the story is going to
be for Justice League two and they've
already started working on that and like
I said the best thing about the movie is
its characters so you will be so excited
about what they're gonna do with the
next Man of Steel movie the next Wonder
Woman movie the flash movie and
obviously Aquaman which is literally the
next movie that's coming out just a
reminder to the Aquaman movie is being
released around this time next year so
it will be another year before you get a
DC movie but I think that after that
because of the changes they've made with
the way they make their films they'll be
able to get to the point where they can
put out two a year so you get like one
in the spring then one in the summer one
at the end of the year so you get more
than one DC film per year but it'll take
them a little while to get up to that
point if you're a person that likes to
follow movie news and you've been
following all the changes that have been
happening behind the scenes like them
bringing in Danny Elfman instead of
junkie XL to do the music for the film
you'll understand exactly why they did
stuff like that
when you see the film why they cut
certain scenes out why they reshot
certain things so I can't talk about
those specifically until I do my review
video so that'll be next Wednesday when
the official embargo is up but I think
the main takeaway is that everybody was
just terrified that this was gonna be a
complete mess and it was going to be a
bad movie and those were completely
unfounded it ended up being a lot of fun
and I do think that they have a lot of
movie hits on their hands like they can
genuinely make an amazing flash movie I
think it just requires the right script
with the right director with the right
people behind the camera this movie
comes much closer to what I think Zack
Snyder was trying to do with Batman vs
Superman so the tone the characters are
balanced a little bit more but like I
said probably like the biggest problem
with the film is that mandate to keep it
under two hours like it really did need
an extra 20 minutes to fill out some
character moments but on the flip side
of that they're always really good with
the DVD releases about putting that
stuff back in so maybe they'll be an
extended cut maybe there'll be bonus
features but I'm assuming there's gonna
be a ton of deleted scenes so it'll be
fun to watch all those what will happen
next is I have some new flash to post
this weekend but there's new Marvel
stuff dropping so just look at the top
pin comment for the videos that I'm
posting next in case my schedule changes
you leave all your requests for Justice
League videos like I said I can't post
my review video till Wednesday night so
that's like when the official review is
allowed to post but there is a new round
of that Justice League take a giveaway
all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber leave a comment on this video
congratulations to Skye otic you're the
winner from the last video please
private message me so I can get your
contact details you can click here for
the first Deadpool - holiday promo and
you can click here for my arrow
Deathstroke Returns video thank you so
much for watching everybody stay awesome
I'll see you guys tonight